Because if you don't get fed that you
don't find out about Julian Assange
getting kicked out of
the embassy in London,
you don't find out about a million
different stories that are in the news.
It's a fun story. It's a cool story,
but do I need to know it? Wow.
It's a fun story. That's a
quote for you from now on. Hey,
what about Shalina such Tom Papa,
hands up in quotes. It's a fun story.
It's a cool story, but I don't
need to know it. Holy Shit. Really?
You just redefined white privilege.
Well, you hit it. You hit it on the head.
Let it off fire. No, it's seriously.
What can I do about a lot
of these? You know, look,
I think it's good that the information
is flowing and that moves everybody
forward, but you know, for me,
sitting in there trying to tell some
jokes and feed my kids, it's like,
do I need to know everything,
every trouble spot going around the world.
It's like,
that is a very good question.
How much responsibility do you have to
be tuned in to all the events of the
world and to act? Or how
much responsibility do you
have outside of voting?
And do you have the
responsibility to vote?
Cause there's some people that are very
interesting people that don't vote. Yeah.
You know, I don't agree with that. Yeah.
I want to participate.
I understand that. Um,
but I don't think Michael Malice
votes doesn't, he does it.
Didn't he say he doesn't vote?
I think he said he doesn't,
I forget his reasoning,
but it was very logical.
Uh Huh. No, I understand
the argument, but I am,
even if it seems kind of false and I just,
I think it kind of like mentally
engages you in the world.
It's like you should be
trying to participate. I think
his perspective is that as I'm
a commentator on the world,
that'd be better off if he didn't
actually vote and just look at it how he
really sees it on both sides.
Right.
If I'm just not sure arcial yeah,
I'm sure I'm butchering
the way he would phrase it.
I think it's in the spirit
of that. Yeah. If you vote,
you don't have a right to complain.
All right. Does it make sense?
That doesn't make any sense.
That was deep. Well, but I think,
uh, but look, it's, it's a lot.
Look,
I think it's trying to be a good person.
I'm just a person level and try and take
care of your family and work hard and
be good with people and
help your community.
That's kind of the extent of what you
can do and hopefully that spreads out.
But you know, Julian Assange. Okay,
Whoa, really? I mean, why
is that? You know? Well,
like all those people that we're talking
about at that generation that only got
news during that six o'clock hour,
you know,
were they less citizens of the world
because they only got that little dose?
I don't know.
They were less informed.
And the idea is that more people can get
away with things they shouldn't be able
to get away with. Like what's happening
right now with Juliana, sarge,
Julian Assange in anybody's estimation.
If look at what he did,
he distributed information
that was extremely interesting
to most people in the
world that didn't know about it.
Right. Exposed a lot of scary shit.
Yeah. I suppose a lot of corruption
as opposed a lot of, um, I mean, what,
what corruption did it expose? I know
it exposed the, there was that, um,
collateral murder video that was the,
one of the first ones where they
showed them shooting. They shot at um,
these guys where they thought
were soldiers and they were,
they were reporters and it was sort
of just the way they dealt with it.
It was very scary for people watching
that someone could just like dehumanize
accidentally killing the wrong people.
I may get like knows the military,
they were making it like, you know, hey,
but you kind of have to be in that
mindset to be able to gun people down from
the sky in the first place.
Oh look,
you gotta put yourself in the perspective
of someone who has to do that job and
you take a regular person.
And then you train them to do that job
and then you asked them to go and pull
the trigger people, they're going to
develop a coldness to them will again,
they have to, right. But to see it.
So what Julian Assange did is he showed
it to us and then he released all sorts
of, I mean, I, I've, I haven't,
I'm embarrassed to say that I haven't
really studied all the files and what was
released, what wasn't. Apparently
when Ben Shapiro was here,
he said that, uh, people's
names got a put out.
Apparently that was someone hacked into
wikileaks and release that information
before they could redact the names.
This was the,
this is what I've been told by multiple
sources. But again, I didn't look into it.
I don't know if that was correct.
So
they're going to say that he
was treasonous or that he was,
I don't know what they're going to say.
I think you're right.
The first thing was a sex charge.
That's what they were trying to say.
That he had sex with a woman,
um,
that where he wore a condom
and then they had sex.
And then they had sex in the morning
with no condom and she didn't consent to
that, that he just kinda did it or
something. I think it was something along,
I think they called it Soprise sex and
if I'm butchering this, I'm sorry. Um,
but the um,
that didn't make sense like that there
would be going after him that way.
Well,
he goes obviously not about that.
You go after if you want to get somebody
to go after him and for whatever.
But I'm like hacking charges
now, right? Yeah. I don't know.
I know he look crazy in
the, in the embassy, right.
He w he wouldn't clean up after his
cat and he was riding a scooter around.
Is that true? That's what I don't know
why? Well, who knows what's driving? No,
that's part of it.
But that's just part of the little
story that I caught the little delta was
soccer was poetically describing what
the embassy was smelled like with Julian
Assange. Dirty cat shit wafting
through the halls. Yeah. Crazy asshole.
Do you have staying here?
Don't leave.
Pamela Anderson comes over every now
and then they get their free con,
the surveillance footage,
footage
of Julian Assan skateboarding in the
Ecuadorian embassy in London has been
linked. Okay. Yeah. But here's the thing,
man. Like what do you want the guy to do?
Is there a problem? He's there for seven
fucking years. He must have gotten crazy.
I mean, that's like being, you know,
under house arrest dude. I mean,
it's amazing that he lasted
that long and what they did,
they waited them out and then when there
were never going to wait him out and he
was gonna stay in there forever
and then I guess got sick of them,
they just get sick of them. I think there
was also of the Ecuadorian President,
I think he took a photograph in front
of a, like some lobsters and shit.
And it was from a leaked email in
that photo got out and it was very
embarrassing to him because his country's
in deep financial crisis and he's
chilling in some four seasons somewhere.
He loves Terrian lobster.